mais des 10es leur maladie avant de
recevoir un rose ici est de parler de
tous les cas on en est sûrs à jean
pierre pernaut et beaucoup d'autres vous
verrez sur au contraire qu'ils nous ont
caché comme témoin une salariée qui a eu
un cancer elle ne l'a jamais dit sauf
quand elle a été soignée et puis plus
récemment retour de vacances pour ceux
qui regardent le service public louis
lafarge lafarge pardon qui a posté une
photo très difficile et on va essayer de
comprendre avec la sociologue pourquoi
est ce compost ce genre de photos là
mais d'abord voilà on va parler un
instant de florent pagny mais justement
récap les stars et la maladie regarder
le temps d'accueillir aux
si florent pagny a fait le choix de
parler ouvertement de sa maladie dans
l'immédiat d'abord c'est pas contagieux
et ensuite ça peut arriver à tout le
monde il n'est pas le premier à avoir
voulu jouer le jeu de la transparence
avec son public en mars 2010 est la
rockstar johnny hallyday avait tenu à
faire taire les rumeurs en annonçant
lui-même sur facebook son cancer
l'affluence de mensonges qui circulent
sur mon état de santé me choque
profondément on m'a effectivement
dépister il ya quelques mois des
cellules cancéreuses pour lesquelles je
suis actuellement traités d'affaires
bernard tapie lui avait déjà annoncé sa
maladie à travers un communiqué et
seulement quelques années plus tard
qu'il a décidé d'en parler ouvertement à
la télé je suis plus mauvais point que
j'ai connus plus tard le présentateur
part du jt de 13 heures jean-pierre
pernaut avait lui décidé de prendre la
parole dans une vidéo tournée depuis
chez lui en novembre 2021 et oui il ya
eu une fuite annonçant dans les médias
que je
souffrait d'un cancer du poumon si
aujourd'hui ces personnalités nous ont
quittés elles ont permis de libérer la
parole sur certaines maladies une
décision pas toujours facile lorsqu'on
est médiatisé à gâteau proulx laurence
boccolini clémentine célarié ont-elles
aussi décidé de s'exprimer sur leur
combat je voulais en parler que quand
que j'étais guérie et que j'allais
guérir parce que si on on parle de ça
les gens ont peur que vous mourriez
cours alors bon je n'allais pas faire
peur à ceux que vous aimez certaines
célébrités préfère quant à elle restée
discrète mais la pression médiatique les
pousse parfois à révéler leur intimité
alors selon vous les stars ont elles
raison de médiatiser leur maladie
je vous dire que dans le sujet on avait
évidemment bernard tapie pernaut johnny
de la rue des gens qu'ils ont quittée
mais faut pas faire ce genre
d'association aujourd'hui plus de 70%
des dd cancer sont traités et se
traitent très bien donc voilà ne soyons
pas négatif à chaque fois mais sont avec
nous justement alors audrey van wittel
si je prolonge bien
on verra avec vous est ce que c'est une
perte pour soi pour les autres beaucoup
de stars comme nicole les hommes et non
et c'est bien pour que les gens
justement se rendre compte que ça peut
nous arriver aussi d'autres disent que
c'est pour enfin on essaiera de tout bon
et c'est très personnel et puis on
campus kroes qui est avec toi
aujourd'hui rose la chanteuse
le premier album en 2006 des tubes et
puis après une carrière que vous avez
raconté en entier vous pour le coup en
suit derrière avec des addictions des
mauvaises élections un bouquin pour vous
en sortir mathilde est bonne c'est très
joli mais je dis moi dis ça ne fait pas
mais en tout cas moi je lit plein de
choses sur vous je trouve ça très
touchant très beau que soient vos
disques vous d'ailleurs ou ce que vous
écrivez et puis en fuite comme la vie
s'acharne un petit peu ma une fois qu'on
sort d'une addiction le confinement
arrive et donc c'est assez récent et la
sortie qu'on du confinement vous vous
poster un tweet ou vous de quoi en gros
je dis tout simplement que je vais faire
une pause aussi parce que en fait
c'était ça tombe exactement au moment où
j'avais décidé de faire une pause parce
que le confinement m'avait mis tout
simplement à l'arrêt voilà pour mai et
est finalement mon corps me mets à
l'arrêt aussi alors peut-être dire aux
gens c'est parce qu'effectivement on
vous dit à la fin du confinement bat pas
concert ouais mais un cancer ouais
c'est un cancer par ma chanson allez un
concert ma chambre en verre donc j'ai
été un cancer bien masqué avec des
médecins masqué personnes pour
m'accompagner parce que c'était pendant
le lock ovi donc ça veut dire compliqué
voulait pas qu'on la vie vous en
remettre une petite commenter les beaux
jours d'huile c'est très bien vous avez
l'air ouais ça va super bien je pense
pas que la vie me s'acharne sur moi au
contraire je pense que la vie me fait
beaucoup de cadeaux c'est très bien pour
en parler
si je dis que vous après avoir été
malade c'est une très bonne nouvelle à
la banque on parle de vous aussi puis de
toutes les stars je m'en confesse un
point sur florent pagny que c'est là une
de closer
aujourd'hui est un pardon au jeu qui
sort cette semaine et donc c'est une de
closer et bien on voit effectivement on
parle de florent pagny est-ce qu'il va
mieux ou pas c'est moi qu'on regarde
d'abord juste avant rappelez vous
c'était il ya quelques mois lorsqu'il
avait annoncé et bien qu'il arrêtait ça
tu aurais pas killer stoppait sa tournée
quitterait pas sa tournée pardon je vais
arriver parce qu'il était malade
souvenez vous je dois annuler l'ensemble
de mes concerts suite à un problème de
santé en effet on vient de me
diagnostiqué une tumeur au poumon
tumeur cancéreuse pas très sympathique
qui ne peut pas s'opérer donc je dois
entrer dans un protocole de six mois de
chimiothérapie et de rayons x vous savez
tous que dans la vie le plus important
c'est la santé et quand on a un problème
il devient prioritaire moi et ma moitié
devons
nous mettre en mode guerrier afin
d'affronter cette cette épreuve un peu
particulière non pas juste le suivant et
on va en parler ensuite bah voilà
quelques mois après quelques semaines
après hilare posté un instagram pour
dire qu'il allait beaucoup mieux que le
savez savez diminue regarder
bonjour à tous je suis à vous donner un
peu de mes nouvelles il est remarqué que
j'étais pas très réseaux sociaux donc je
vous ai pas imposer une série netflix
sur mon traitement et et mon histoire
mais bon maintenant qu'elle est bientôt
derrière moi puisqu'il ne me reste plus
qu une chimio
je peux vous dire que je vais très bien
oui j'ai un peu changé de look le
protocole a plutôt bien marché puisque
dès les deux premières chimio
immunothérapie ma tumeur qui était
grosse comme un kiwi s'est transformé en
une noisette j'ai été très bien
accompagné médicalement j'étais très
bien accompagné par ma moitié mes
enfants et puis il ya eu ce phénomène de
synchronicité avec ses milliers de
messages et de témoignages d'amour de
soutien de bonnes ondes je pense que ça
aussi ça a contribué à me permettent de
passer cet cette histoire de cette
manière alors de plus rassurant les
photos dans closer il a repris du poids
il va très bien et on embrasse mais
comment il va justement aujourd'hui où
est-ce qu'on en ait en étant honnête
alors justement je précise que le closer
qu'on voit à l'écran c'est celui de la
semaine dernière comprendre pourquoi
j'explique ça c'est qu'en fait au moment
où on publie sa il attend les résultats
d'un scanner d'accord n'est pas encore
trois sont censés être très rassurant
ouais pourquoi part si la tête comment
ont ils s'en servent voilà et parce
qu'il a terminée donc son protocole de
radiothérapie et de chimiothérapie et
c'est vrai que ça s'est très bien passé
moi sur ce que je sais qu'il n'est pas
dans le journal mais que je sais c'est
qu'au départ il le dit la taille de sa
tumeur et d'autres raisons font qu'elle
est inopérable moi j'ai eu quelqu'un
très bien placé sur le plan médical et
qui traite ce genre de de tumeurs qui
m'a expliqué qu'en gros l'objectif c'est
de la faire diminuer au maximum pour
pouvoir opérer juste n'a pas d'accord et
à l'heure où on se parle il est en tout
cas moi je ne suis pas au courant d'une
opération programmée concernant florent
pagny d'accord donc a priori pour qu'une
guérison soit totale on n'est jamais
totale est sûre mais vraiment envisagé
il faudrait plus en passer par là voilà
pour vraiment statuer et lui ai dit que
pour l'instant il est encore un petit
peu de mal à voyager ses douze heures
pour la patagonie qui veut pas faire
l'avion parce que c'est donc au doute
que si les du mal à faire 12 heures
d'avion c'est qu'il est encore assez
faible oui mais ils l'ont autorisé à
rentrer juste bien sûr en argentine et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que fin
novembre il sera pas là puisqu'il est
supposé ce moment là être en argent que
ça mais les nouvelles sont bonnes c'est
juste qu'elle ferait un petit peu de
temps et j'ai brusquement vous demandez
le fait comme ça qu'ils qui communiquent
et qu'on a l'impression qu'il veut
s'auto persuader aussi de choses
puisqu'il le dit allez on se revoit dans
quatre mois je fais la tournée alors que
je pense que même s'il est en pleine
voie de guérison enfin les médecins
savaient que dans quatre mois il pourra
pas faire sa tournée qui serait pas
assez fort qui sait cette manière de
communiquer comme il l'a fait lui qui
potentiel public en disant je vais dans
quatre mois on fait une tournée du coup
les fans étaient comme ça
non ils s'auto persuadent de quelque
chose oui en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que en tant que personnalité publique
que ce n'est pas en tant que célébrité
il ya là quand même là valeurs
d'authenticité qui est très préconisé
dans notre société qui fait que
l'individu aujourd'hui pour être bien vu
bien perçu qu'il soit une célébrité ou
un cri dame doit être nette par rapport
à lui même et par rapport aux autres
mais en ce qui concerne florent pagny
aussi cette volonté en fait de préserver
une belle image de lui même il à vis de
son public parce qu'il reste malgré tout
une vedette et quelqu'un qui doit
toujours incarné quand même quelque
chose de 2,2 hors du commun
d'exceptionnel voyez donc être confronté
à ce risque de finitude être confrontés
se mettre en vulnérabilité d'un côté ça
fait une force puisque a l'air de
l'authenticité à partir du moment où une
célébrité va communiquer sur son
mal-être sur ces traitements elle va
recueillir vraiment la tendresse et
l'attention du public et on voit ici que
florent pagny dit qu'en fait j'ai une
synchronicité avec tous les messages
qu'il a reçus de la part des fans et que
ça sans doute pour ça a sans doute dû
contribuer à sa guérison envoyé va
effectivement il ya quelque chose de
l'ordre de l'auto-persuasion et d'aller
de l'avant en rond je vais tenir pour
mon public à la route dans une question
pourquoi vous vous avez ce besoin de
communiquer aussi pas d'en parler tout
de suite au public comme vous l'avez
fait à la 8e c'est quoi ça c'est des
matchs aux antilles comme
moi c'était une bonne excuse à ce moment
là d'une bonne quoi bonne excuse pour
pour faire une pause parce que j'avais
ouais j'avais souffert pendant le coc
vise et j'avoue que j'ai pas compris
tout de suite qu'on m'annonce et moi le
cancer je les prix comme une bonne
excuse aux débuts bizarrement dix ans
ben voilà en fait je suis forcé
maintenant de faire une pause je dois
changer ma façon de fonctionner ma
factions de ma façon de travailler ma
façon d'écrire je ne voulais plus faire
que de la musique j'avais envie de faire
d'autres choses et je me suis dit tiens
ça va être le bon moment oui mais
d'accord mais est ce que par exemple le
fait qu' il est ma guise je tape sur
personne mais qui les magazines comme
voilà closer qui essaient de savoir où
vous en êtes ce qui se passe avant le
fait que de la rue par exemple avait
communiqué en disant moi je communique
je ne voulais pas le faire mais obligé
parce qu'un médecin a pas quelqu'un à
piquer mon dossier médical johnny
hallyday aussi avait dit sur facebook
voilà je viens dire que je suis malade
parce qu'on me force parce que la presse
people qui lui dit ça veut dire qu'ils
ont aussi des people qui veulent pas le
dire mais qui sont obligés par ce qui
est de la presse people est ce que dans
votre cas ce que vous avez ressenti
comme poids et puis j'ai pas cette
notoriété là malheureusement parce que
c'est johnny oui bien sûr mais j'adore
mais non mais non
c'est pas ça c'est que je pense
honnêtement que sélection d'amour les
gens aiment leur idole ouais ces gens là
ont vraiment réussi est ce qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui et à combattre même leur
maladie peut-être soins grâce à leurs
fans les fans ont peur que cette
personne meurt comme si c'était un
proche voire plus je comprends que qui
doivent être informés c'est quelqu'un de
leur famille et moi j'aimerais un tour
de table aussi par les pardons honda
parle aussi de jean pierre pernaut
nathalie marquay en fait toutes ces gens
qui qui qui communiquent j'aimerais
faire un tour de table toi comment tu te
sens encore une fois c'est compliqué de
juger quand on est pas des malades
étaient connus comment tu te sens
vis-à-vis toi de tout ces people qui
communique aujourd'hui je trouve ça
extrêmement bien je trouve que c'est
nouveau ça libère la parole ça permet
surtout aux gens qui sont malades chez
eux des mêmes types de maladies je pense
à beaucoup de deux cancers féminins
notamment même pas que aussi pour ça va
ce qu'une d'en parler de montrer que ça
arrive à n'importe qui que ce soit y
qu'il faut pas avoir de tabou qu'il faut
être sincère dont ceux là et voilà moi
j'ai aucun souci là seul truc que je
veux dire c'est que quand tu ne veux pas
en parler parce que c'est à son corps
soit je trouve scandaleux des gens aux
people on parle à ta place je trouve
même un peu scandaleux que ce journal la
m il a vaincu son insert je trouve que
c'est un peu too much et de la croche et
la [ __ ] à cliquer c'est pour faire
vendre des alors pardon hein pour closer
mais voilà je trouve qu il a vaincu son
cancer point d'exclamation ça ouais
non disent que maxime et j'ai dormi à
bâle en bas mekouar mai valait pas donc
on en public un jour aller nous raconter
que la la la tumeur faisait tant de
centimètres de machin c'est totalement
un dossier médical ça n'a rien à [ __ ]
dans publiquement pardon ok qui n'est
pas d'accord avec ce qu'a dit laurent
moi ça me tenait de matraques par dont
j'aimerais bien avoir l'avis de l'avis
contraire qui se pensent qu'au contraire
c'est bien gagner en garder un peu de
pudeur c'est moi départ je me souviens
que j'avais été assez choqué quand on
voyait toutes les couvertures avec
ingrid chauvin sais pas si vous vous
rappelez mais vraiment toutes les
couvertures elle parlait de sa fausse
couche et voilà et c'était non-stop et
galas et machins et la fausse couche je
me suis dit c'est pas mal de nouilles un
moment donné qu'on passe pas une maladie
c'est un dysfonctionnement chez la femme
voilà qui est un petit peu honteux somme
la maladie est honteuse et en fait je
trouve que c'est bien finalement que la
parole se libère parce que ça enlève
cette honte qu'il y a il ya aussi l'ex
femme de marc lavoine qui a fait un
bouquin là tu as lease ninh binh papa
aussi sur les fausses couches ou
l'endométriose là tout ce qui touche un
petit peu on va là aux femmes aux seins
à la gynécologie
finalement je suis assez d'accord avec
toi mais c'est vrai qu'au départ je me
suis dit mais quel est l'intérêt au
qu'aux pires qu'une star et j'ai posé la
question à rodez culte star doit pas
aussi je restais une star entre
guillemets est ce qu'on a envie de
connaître les problèmes françoise hardy
nous raconte qu'elle a des problèmes et
qu'elle va aux toilettes et que massin
quelques john nous raconte que des
touches est combien il a bien expliqué
il a dit je vous ai pas imposer une
série netflix ouais c'est génial il
rassure ses fans oui oui donc la vérité
il a fait trois messages je trouve ça
parfaitement moi même c'est les
magazines j'ai un problème avec les
stars qui ont envie de dire à leurs fans
je vais où je vais mal ses matches alors
oui florian et puis après j'aimerais
aussi l'avis de jeu ray professeur
audrey notamment laurent déjà jour un
truc que j'ai déjà dit sur ce plateau
c'est que la presse people ne révèle
jamais une maladie surtout quand elle
est très grave à l'étranger 6 mai en
france jamet c'est une règle d'or je
savais pas revenir quasiment jamais été
transgressée florent pagny là on se
permet on se permette parce qu'il
est fini florent pagny la closer il va
parce que il en a parlé de lui-même
comme l'avait fait pernaut comme et
après pour ce qui est de la une et du
papier qui à l'intérieur comme je
voulais aussi déjà expliqué ça c'est un
truc qu'on est d'accord ou pas que la
presse people utilise beaucoup ont fait
parler les photos et là c'est vrai que
ses cheveux repoussent à barberousse il
se balade dans la rue avec son épouse on
sait que le protocole etc fonctionné et
c'est donc la direction a décidé de pas
mois de titrer comme ça mais voilà
j'explique juste juste audrey je tiens à
parler quand on a vu la photo ci par là
aussi si de louis laforge prouve que
tout le monde connaît louis laforge que
ceux fabriqués sur france info france
info merci beaucoup et puis sur france 3
aussi enfin voilà l'udc est tellement
public est tellement france télévisions
on ne sait rien de lui il est pas dans
la presse people en fait c'est vraiment
le journaliste qui est très journalistes
n'y a pas de vie privée quand on a vu
cette photo sur instagram en retour de
vacances merci beaucoup
j'avais d'abord on sait le bac il était
malade moi le premier c'est comme
quelqu'un de très connu et où cette
photo de la part de quelqu'un d'assez
pudique et qu'est ce qu'elle veut dire
en fait pourquoi il pourquoi poster ça
je pense que ça correspond vraiment à un
devoir qui l'a qu'il pense avoir à
l'égard de son public par rapport à
cette règle d'authenticité de dire je
suis honnête avec moi même je suis
honnête avec les autres et en fait il
m'arrive quelque chose de grave et je
peux pas continuer à mentir latuquois
donc je révèle vraiment soit plus de 500
photos et du javelot et à vue alors un
peu de name dropping pardon j'avais eu
mon ami paul jean marc roger au
téléphone et il le connaît très bien les
bosses et à bec et me dis-je il est
tellement pudique j'ai pas compris que
je ne sais pas si je devais être choqués
et en fait ils me disent j'ai compris tu
sais j'ai compris la fin je vais fermer
le choix j'ai compris mais départ de
trucs moches il avait besoin je crois
dada du de dire je suis guéri j'ai eu
une pulsion de vie je joue le montrer tu
vois je crois que c'est ça ou rica c'est
la pudeur parfois la maladie elle peut
créer des trucs absolument incroyable
chez les gens psychologiquement
ah oui bah je pense ouais mais tu as
raison tu es malade public ou parmi nous
ça peut casser des trucs ou alors état
d'un peu trop forcé ou détruire ça vous
aura pensé ça fait ou la wii ah oui
alors oui c'est le jour et la nuit c'est
que vous êtes pardon mais quand je vous
écoute vous avez été ressort un cancer
du sein et ouais c'est vrai non je suis
heureuse d'avoir des épreuves quand je
suis dans les épreuves j'ai envie de
crever comme tout le monde en fait je me
rends compte après par contre j'aimerais
pas j'avais des photos quand on enlève
un sage aurait pu les poster pour faire
de la peine à tout le monde pour faire
le buzz pour dire et je suis authentique
non je trouve ça un peu déplacé ça
m'intéresse pas moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est d'être honnête en fait avec le
coeur c'est pas en montrant des îles à
sion j'ai pas été heureuse quand j'étais
dedans parce que moi j'ai connu l'enfer
des effets secondaires delà du
traitement et le cancer je les ai pas
vaincu un cancer on cancer n'était pas
aussi dangereux que certains cancers mon
pronostic vital n'était pas engagé donc
dès le début pour moi le cancer ça a été
un choix difficile way en chemin et j'ai
parcouru ce chemin et malheureusement
j'ai sombré parce que l'hormonothérapie
cne rien à voir avec l'immunothérapie
de notre ami que j'aime
florent pagny et je suis très heureux de
le voir comme ça c'est l'hormonothérapie
c'est la mise en repos des ovaires donc
une 1h une ménopause violente d'un coup
et donc on perd tout envie de tout
j'utilise haye après château oui là
encore il ya tous les cas de figure dans
le cap fanni il était obligé de
mediative de toute façon parce qu'avec
the void ça n'aurait pas pu passer
inaperçue alain pluss c'est sa nature
d'affronter de dire nous fait chier et
je le dis du mal à moi benoît ya eu
comme françoise hardy qui ont toujours
parlé super cadre donc là dessus elle
est super cache aussi oui ça me fait
chier de billets ou ça me fait chier de
mourir et voilà ce que j'ai et voilà et
puis il ya ceux qui en parlent et sophie
il ya ce pardon qui enfant non pas un
commerce mais qui sur médiatise la chose
c'est un impact médiatique
il ya plein de dettes sur l'endométriose
je connais plein de cas où il y en a 50
% qui était très authentique et 50% qui
ont surfé sur la vague médiatique il
faut pas exclure que ça existe aussi ici
nous mêmes on est pris comme des relais
souvent moi je me souviens d'une
interview qu'une vedette qui m'a dit bon
vous allez me parler de ça alors
parlons-en tout de suite il dit pas du
tout j'en ai mais pas l'intention et
j'en ai toujours pas l'intention
d'accord tamponnades donc là aussi il ya
tous les cas de figure faut pas non plus
tomber dans le panneau des fois non là
où je rejoins rose moi c'est le dire ou
l'écrire je suis d'accord moi le voir
franchement j'ai pas envie c'est ça et
faire un fonds de commerce une
communication avec de la photo mais
vraiment racoleuse pour pouvoir revenir
existe et il y en a qui en profitent de
ce système de cette maladie pour revenir
pour écrire des livres pour en faire
tout des tartines et des tartines et
août après que ce soit comme elle veut
peut-être que ça leur apporte du
réconfort mais parfois j'ai l'impression
que c'est too much pour pouvoir exister
ou redevenu ou revenir sur le devant de
la scène attends juste un mot de m ouais
moi je pense qu'il faut arrêter de voir
le mal partout je pense qu'il faut pas
oublier qu'il a permis notion de partage
derrière je trouve ça toujours très
intéressant justement d'avoir des des
témoignages comme c'est le cas de rose
ou des témoignages comme c'est le cas de
lock de forêt failli il ya des concerts
il ya des contraintes professionnelles
parfois on n'a pas le choix on le subit
parce que quand on se justifie pas sur
les réseaux sociaux on nous en met plein
la gueule à on sait pas ce qu est ce qui
se passe il a annulé son concert on sait
pas où il est assez de la feignantise on
est obligés parfois de se justifier il
n'y a pas le choix et il faut aussi dire
et je terminerai là-dessus pardon que
les fans ont besoin de savoir et ont
envie de savoir ce qui se passe dans la
vie de leur style leur appartient c'est
à dire que l inverse si on prend des
gens qui refusent de communiquer
clémentine célarié par exemple éboué
beaucoup d'autres qui ont une maladie
guillaume durand pareil ils l'ont dit
dallas à la fin totale celle que c'est
en europe en revanche ne respectent pas
leurs fans communiqué klaus
avec parce que lui vraiment ces
personnes ont vraiment intégré le fait
que en tant que personnalité publique en
fait elles n'ont pas le droit de faillir
leur clémentine célarié à d'autres et
elle a déclaré que l on a parlé quand
elle était guéri voilà c'est à dire
qu'elle voulait vraiment préserver cette
image de perfection d'admiration qu'on a
par rapport à elle parce que la mise en
vulnérabilité d'une personnalité
publique c'est toujours quand même une
gageure quelque part one est donc
vraiment ce besoin oui peut-être mais là
je rejoins laurent c'est que je crois je
touche du bois bien sûr pour tout le
monde autour de tables et moi aussi je
vois qu'en réalité aulas c'est de la
fiction ce qu'on fait parce qu'on ne
sait pas comment réagira ou comment
réagirait si on était malade et tu
oublies une catégorie dans les docks tu
présentes ce qui n'en parle même pas
quand ils ont guéri moi je disais que la
menace people ne révèle pas ah oui les
maladies moi je connais fin gd je sais
que certains animateurs certaines
célébrités françaises ont été touchées
ont guéri n'ont jamais parlé il ya que
leurs amis et leur famille qu'ils le
savent grosse journée précise donc ce
bouquin dans lequel vous expliquer tout
ce ce combat en fait voilà il ya vu un
premier bouquin vous avez des sorties et
fantastique était fantastique et rozenn
non merkel ou parler des addictions
alcool vous parlez
vous pas que c'est trop beau vous avez
des 26 ans vous êtes monté trop haut
trop fort et cet album et puis après
comment on gère tout ça ouais enfin
voilà qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter
que ça que ça continue comme jeu comme
c'est aujourd'hui c'est à dire avec ces
nouveaux yeux qui me permettent de voir
la vie du bon côté enfin j'ai la chance
d'avoir des épreuves et donc jeu j'en
suis j'essaie d'en être digne balla vous
en avez assez merci beaucoup
devraient également 2005 était seul à
l'état de tout